Naomi es una de los 36 Afortunados que
ha ganado una licencia para vender
marihuana legalmente en Nueva York
Gracias la noticia llegó a finales de
noviembre para ella fue toda una
sorpresa salir triunfadora entre más de
900 aplicantes estaba llorando saltando
de un lado a otro estaba yo y mi familia
estábamos súper felices Yo no lo podía
creer le acompañamos a este primer
encuentro de nuevos empresarios en el
mundo del Cannabis una cita que le
permitirá conocer las últimas novedades
del mercado así como elegir elementos de
decoración y consumo para su futuro
dispensario
antes de que acabe el año el gobierno
neoyorquino le cederá un local para que
venda Cannabis
Este es un vaporizador en el que puedes
poner flores allí luego tirar y luego
fumar hoy ha venido sola pero al frente
del negocio le acompañará su hermano
gracias a él consiguieron la licencia
porque era el candidato perfecto
vengo de una familia que sufrió la ley
por la guerra contra las drogas con mi
hermano teniendo condenas y cuando
hicieron públicos los requisitos de lo
que nada más para aplicar yo sabía que
calificábamos así que apliqué
Lo mismo hizo cosmarte que todavía
espera ganar una de las 114 licencias
que el estado repartirá este mes cuando
se enteró de que tenían prioridades
miembros de comunidades atacadas y
discriminadas en la guerra contra las
drogas supo que debía aplicar
policía en el vecindario de nosotros que
cualquier otro vecindario cuando dices
nosotros A qué te refieres Bueno lo
Moreno y lo hispano nunca imaginó que la
experiencia y sus 6 años en prisión por
tráfico de drogas le ayudarían en su
futuro profesional
yo creo porque yo sé mercado bien Yo
creo que me deben dar la licencia
gracias a cosomarte Naomi y el resto de
nuevos comerciantes legales de marihuana
las autoridades esperan recaudar cerca
de 350 millones de dólares anuales en
impuestos por la venta de cannabis